they say that death is cheap in anime
especially a lot of shown in series
however some characters just have
immortality as a power talked about the
greatest power of them all or is if
after all immortality can be a curse in
itself as we'll be seeing soon enough
for now here are some of the immortal
characters that I find cool charming or
straight-up charismatic
one of the most iconic villains in Jojo
cars leader of the pillar man has
cemented his legacy on one thing besides
the massacre of his own clan complete
immortality as soon as he becomes the
perfect life-form
Kars has reached the peak that a lot of
villains can only hope to achieve
immortality unfortunately for him though
it's this much designed ability that
finally does him in after all unkillable
and undefeatable are completely
different things as he'll learned the
hard way despite falling in just the
second saga of Jojo I still dare say
that Kars is the single most powerful
character in universe and that statement
has a lot to do with his immortality
next we have demon slayers demon
predecessor Mouzon for anime only
watches there's surprisingly little that
can be said of Mouzon he had his famous
first appearance where he looked like
Michael Jackson and a second one where
he appeared as a woman and did the
classic villain cliche of killing his
own minions massan's an outlier in this
list and he's actually not immortal in
the literal sense of the word for one he
was nearly killed sometime in the past
and two he remains afraid of the Sun
giving how hard it is to actually kill
him and his longevity he might as well
be treated as an immortal villain one
that poses the biggest challenge to the
demon slayer corpse so far we haven't
seen that much of moves on from the
anime but trust me when we get to the
inevitable next season that covers the
future arcs of the manga and Mozart's
backstory you're gonna be in for a world
of surprise just for a little hint
without spoiling you guys let me just
say that it's physically impossible to
kill Mouzon with the traditional demon
slayer methods
and number eight we have one of the
seven deadly sins
it's barn some of the toughest that most
badass characters come with the most
tragic backstories what I say the barns
is the most tragic of them all he's sure
has one hell of a background to
introduce once a bandit who sought
immortality barn would set his sights on
the Fountain of Youth a run-in with The
Fountains guardian Elaine would cause
the two to develop feelings for each
other
alas happiness doesn't last long for
bond and a demon attack would lead to
Elaine sacrifice she grants bond the
immortality he long wanted while
sacrificing her own life I guess living
forever sucks when you now have to deal
with that kind of emotional baggage but
luckily for him he meets Mellie Otis and
joins the seven deadly sins with new
adventure on the horizon Redemption
could be a hand for barn
[Music]
next on the list is the notorious dark
wizard zeref being immortal has its
perks but for some the inability to die
also comes as a curse in zareff's case
immortality is seen as the latter
because in reality Zahra found himself
struck by a curse one that kills all
that he loves on the other hand the said
curse does give him immortality within
the meaningless abyss of life fans who
just started watching fairytale would be
surprised to know that the one known as
the darkest and most evil wizard of them
all was once a promising wizard with
tremendous power orchestrating many
events that led to the present timeline
in fairy tale he was just a tormented
youth who failed to find happiness in
every corner then all he wanted was to
die and get it over and done with
too bad that he's a mortal now right
after seeing how far the world has gone
and what crimes have been done in his
name zareff then orchestrates a great
war hoping to one day find his freedom
from the life that chains him to this
world hope is on the horizon as he
believes that he'll finally find the
sweet release of death in this war
he's someone you didn't expect to see on
this list right everyone's favorite
naughty vampire is here and she can pack
one hell of a punch at full power kiss
show is by far the most powerful
character in the series and she has had
a lot of chances to show off her power
in the entire moniker 3 series how could
you match a vampire girl capable of
literally ending the world on a whim
than finding herself alive when it's all
said and done she shot a character who
got tired of life and tried killing
herself but of course that didn't stick
now did it however in her more popular
iteration she mostly hangs around
araragi and acts as the series resident
legal lolly she's over 500 years old
okay
[Music]
the father of the homunculus and the one
behind everything wrong in the series
you'd have expected a lot from him
everyone's expectations were on point as
the moment father made his presence felt
in Full Metal Alchemist we all got a
glimpse of how overpowered he is the
destruction of Xerxes gave him his
signature immortality but his power goes
way beyond that to say that he's almost
a god in the world of Full Metal
Alchemist
not too far from the truth actually
given his capabilities it's no surprise
that he holds humans with such disdain
in a somewhat literal sense at the end
of the series Father really became God
over puny humans who could only hope to
contest him with pathetic alchemic
powers his own pride is most likely the
only key to his undoing so many koi
disco it's already a given that Ginn
Thomas resident broken villain atsuo
would find himself on this list in some
sort of capacity his impressive track
record of wins in battle aside what
makes a surah so scary is his
immortality those regenerative powers
are insane I'm telling you even if he
gets burnt with no trace of him
remaining he still finds some way to
keep coming back the slightest remnant
of him would result in in piecing
himself together again in some form
nevermind the combat skills and
expertise with the sword all previous
Gintama villains are nothing compared to
the Beast that is at zero where else
would you see an arc driven by a villain
seeking his own death because he's just
too overpowered and immortal I guess is
Arif kind of counts but it's quite a
different context and Asura's just more
broken and cooler in universe not your
everyday vampire with him probably being
the most overpowered and broken anime
vampire there is it would be more
accurate to call a low card a force of
nature the blood knight vampire that
lust for battle has remained one of the
most enduring characters from the 2000s
thanks to the cultural impact of Helsing
in addition to his unique vampire powers
our god of course has some stock power
such as transformation one of those is
the classic vampire immortality only
that his version is extreme enough you
can match a lokar's regenerative
capabilities as much like a Zorro
blowing him to bits will not stick at
all there really is no way to kill this
monster along with his other powers that
kind of immortality is enough to give a
loo card a high spot on this list the
only reason that he's not at the top is
because his charisma is bested by just
one other character in Shonen anime what
seal it's cut out to you in wha
call you man or you
how could we have a top immortal
characters list and forget one of the
most popular mainstays and most
charismatic villains in Bleach ambitious
driven and manipulative Aizen has made a
name for himself as one of the most
influential anime villains in the 2000s
while I think that a part of Aizen
staying power in the series stems from
his cunning and raw power
what bore him completely over the top is
his immortality thanks to the hogyoku
look at it this way even if his body
were to be completely eradicated as long
as the gem exists Aizen would be brought
back to life stronger than ever
removing the gem from his body also
doesn't work there's just no way
actually around his immortality you
cannot kill him all you can do is try to
contain him and pray that it sticks but
given how thorough of a chess master
Aizen is good luck with that anyway
Aizen finally got his wish of standing
tall at the top by beating out nine
other contenders for the title of the
best immortal character in anime and
that more or less wraps it up looks like
death really is cheap in the world of
anime huh just how would you gameplan
for fighting these guys in a battle to
the death as usual like and subscribe
for more videos like this and hit the
bell button to make sure to get all the
notifications and be the first in line
for the next video see you guys for the
next one
[Music]
okay